the author of the seven principles of
fat burning Dr Eric ber Dr Eric Berg's
popular book seven principles of fat
burning explores this concept Dr Berg
believes that each body type predisposes
someone to certain health problems we're
back on health and fitness Friday again
with Dr Eric B you burn 900 calories but
no actual weight loss favorite lemon
juice talian volcano lemon juice so
organic lemon juice ketones are the
byproduct of fat metabolism I mean how
many kids at parties at school they're
drinking the apple juice thinking it's
better than soda uh in the break you
were talking to us about losing weight
in your sleep I've got to hear about
this how does this work and is it true
I've got on the diet plan I started the
treatments I have lost some weight I've
swung down I look much better I feel
much better I have more energy the cobs
the bread the pasta the alcohol you can
clean this up so fast and bring it back
to normal range shifting your goal to
getting more healthy and that specific
body type to actually improve it as
compared to trying to put everyone on
the same exercise and eathing Planet
doesn't work the causes of IOD
deficiencies there's direct causes and
indirect causes the key is getting that
recovery when you work out if you're not
going to do that then don't overe
exercise or don't even
exercise my mission my goal my purpose
is to give people the simple truths on
health so they can create a healthier
body you know we all have the power to
heal we the power to get healthy but we
just don't have the knoow the knowledge
is missing there is no Health in health
care anymore we become dependent on
prescription medications in the last 27
years of practice I've treated over
40,000 patients and trained over 2700
doctors my purpose my mission my goal is
to help people find the simple truths of
health so they can create a healthier
body